the gear is 2014. Flappy Birds is
increasing the global rage index by 100
people going a bit mental putting a bit
of cold water over their heads I'm
working for a small little company no
one's ever heard of called the big black
[ __ ] and an anime called Tokyo Ghoul
starts airing this damn thing became
inescapable if you were on Tumblr you'd
see that goddamn edgy mask at every
convention you'd go to and the world was
introduced to one of the most iconic
anime openings of all time unravel if
Renee circulation was the weeb smash hit
song This became our national anthem
come on don't lie at one point I know
the beginning of this song was ingrained
into your brain and you wish you could
match that raspy scratchy ass vocal
texture the singer has
you're welcome headphone users well the
anime didn't exactly explode onto the
scene it was one of those shows that
wormed its way into Anime Pop Culture
within the last 10 years shits the
eighth most popular anime of all time on
Mal behind Naruto and above Demon Slayer
with the manga comfortably sitting at
number five you've seen memes and manga
panels from Tokyo Ghoul spread around
most likely this one which you know is
from that famous scene in the manga
where I think Ken kaneki said I am the
Tokyo Ghoul
[Laughter]
I think it goes on to mob after that and
seeing all this unfold before my eyes I
always had one question
why Tokyo Ghoul I remember watching the
anime thinking well this is a decently
interesting Shonen show bit edgy but
nothing I'm gonna write home about then
like locusts swords of margaritas would
swarm around me and proudly exclaim
um but did you actually read the Manga
it's so much better and I saw kaneki's
white hair and his fabulous black nails
and I was like okay Margaritas whatever
you say now isn't that a Jungkook fan
cam should be busy working on right now
I'm just saying Tokyo Ghoul is a deep
complex story and Ken kaneki is such a
tragic character that nobody understands
and I take offense to that last line
it's a gym in fan cam I'm working on
actually and so eight years later way
past the point anyone still cared about
Tokyo Ghoul I thought huh maybe it's
finally the right time to actually give
this a chance and
God damn it
the manga reader
one punch man the strongest is a one
punch man turn-based mobile RPG that is
officially licensed and open
over some of the most iconic scenes from
the anime in the palm of your hand
saitama isn't the only one though as
there are over 60 characters including
heroes and villains each with their own
unique abilities from Speedo sound Sonic
to the psychic sisters hellish blizzard
and terrible tornado for all you culture
gentlemen out there and everyone here is
voiced by their original Japanese cast
members depending on who you have
choosing the right team comp and
strategy is extremely important for
every battle you can even call insideama
to one punch an enemy but he can only be
used once per battle so use him wisely
join saitama as you investigate the city
and decide on his daily training routine
which includes his usual push-ups
sit-ups squats and running you can also
call on saitama to quickly gather items
for training the characters on your team
the game has already reached 1 million
pre-registrations and all new players
will receive a free Temple old hand
Avatar and appearance frames and if you
log in every day for a week you get 40
additional pools the A-Class hero yairon
as well as a character of your choice so
what are you waiting for click the link
in the description or scan the QR code
to download the game today on iOS or
Android and you can also use promo code
opmts for extra rewards to help you
train your strongest team thank you very
much for one punch man the strongest for
sponsoring us today and back to the
video hiding in the underbelly of
society is the secret world of ghouls
carnivorous monsters that may look act
and sound exactly like humans except
they are stronger faster have superhuman
abilities but most importantly they have
a hunger they need to satisfy one that
cannot be quelled by normal food it's a
hunger that is only Satisfied by
feasting on the Flesh of humans
Ken Carnegie wants [ __ ]
my man my boy's out here just trying to
get laid and scores a lucky day but
unfortunately for our boy before he can
start eating the [ __ ] the [ __ ] starts
seeing him
luckily he's saved by some falling beans
except both of them get crushed and to
save his life the doctors thought it
would be a great idea to just transplant
this random lady's organs into Carnegie
without knowing that she was a ghoul
[Music]
and so begins Carnegie's journey into
the world of ghouls as he slowly learns
to accept that he has become one on the
surface Tokyo Ghoul is a series I didn't
think would appeal to me because when I
looked at the show the Aesthetics and
the fan base I went wait a minute ghouls
are just re-skinned vampires this is a
Vampire series I'll be honest I'm just
not a big fan of Vampire shows sure
there are definitely some cool ones but
a lot of the times it's just not my vibe
especially the ones I see that have dark
sexy
[Music]
oh it's so mysterious
doesn't have any hair in his nipples I
call them Tumblr shows which seeing how
popular Tokyo Ghoul got on there just
reaffirms my preconceptions because you
gotta admit some of these Aesthetics
radiate I'm 14 and this is deep energy
the type show with the fan base you
wouldn't be surprised buying a jar of
corpse husband's bath water and posting
images like there are two wolves inside
of me one wants to eat the other wants
to eat maybe I'm just [ __ ] fat and at
the beginning it seemed like pretty much
that ghouls eat humans so ghouls equal
bad Carnegie good because he's fighting
against Bad ghouls but when I started to
really see what the story was about was
with the introduction of the ccg or the
organization that was created to hunt
ghouls we get introduced to this guy and
I mean just [ __ ] look at him I can
put on a red spacesuit and run down the
street shouting Among Us and I would
still look less sauce than this guy he
shouldn't be that near a playground let
alone a position of authority so when we
see him taking pleasure and murdering a
young ghoul's mother we kind of start to
realize wait a weird about it before you
know it different factions start forming
on both the ghoul and Human Side of
Things each with their own philosophies
of the right course of action to take
Tokyo Ghoul crafts this world where the
conflict just feels organic every single
character has a reason they're part of
this fight a part of this war and it
always feels Justified no matter how
scummy a person they may be sometimes
humans are the monsters sometimes ghouls
are the monsters a lot of the times both
are the monsters and in between there
are a select few just trying to find
peace in all this chaos chaos take your
ghoul tricks you into thinking this is a
story of the struggles of ghouls trying
to find a way to exist in the world of
humans and then halfway through it's
like psyched [ __ ] here's Tokyo goree
where we shift perspectives to the
opposite side of things and see the
sacrifices humans need to make to
protect themselves from the destruction
and despair Googles can bring you can't
blame ghouls for needing to consume the
diets they need to survive any more that
you can blame humans for defending
themselves from being the hunted in this
world there are no good guys and bad
guys just guys trying to survive in the
place they were born in and are willing
to fight with their life on the line to
protect it every character has their own
biases their own prejudices and the more
you find out about them the less you can
blame them for feeling the way they do
and that's what I feel sets up what
makes this series truly shine which is
kaneki himself now I fully admit at the
beginning every time kaneki opened his
mouth I let out big sigh and I roll
because it was a bit like
but as the series progresses you see
that he's the perfect character to carry
you through this story he's someone
who's born as a human that was turned
into a ghoul and as such acts as the
perfect Middle Ground between the two
worlds here is someone who sees the
Twisted unfair broken world for what it
is and because of that he's in a
constant internal battle with himself
unable to fully let go of his human side
but unable to fully accept his ghoul
side there are two wolves and xylophone
sorry sorry can resist the dynamic of
kaneki's internal struggle was to me
what made this manga so compelling
little by little you get to see the
transformation of this naive young whiny
annoying brats become a symbol of the
two sides he represents Tokyo Ghoul is
kaneki's story through and through and
seeing his journey and how it ties in
thematically with the story being told
by the ending of re I could absolutely
see you why he became one of the most
iconic characters in the world of manga
all this just because Ken Carnegie wants
perfect one thing that absolutely stands
out is the art on display here you can
see sui Ishida starting off a bit rough
at the beginning but as the series goes
on you can really see him coming to his
own not only resulting in some legendary
panels but just becoming an absolute
Master being able to portray a person's
mental state kaneki's internal conflict
wouldn't have hit nearly as hard if the
Maga wasn't able to so skillfully convey
the raw mess of emotions people can go
through dialogue bleeds in and out of
speech bubbles paneling loses all sense
of structure the page breaks down just
as much as the characters do when ishido
wants to show you a character's inner
thoughts you don't just see it you feel
it one of my favorite moments is when
they introduce the concept of each ccg
officer having to write a will and
testament before they go off on a
dangerous operation just in case and we
spend some time just seeing a few
people's different approaches some send
the final message to their family some
just detail who gets what assets then we
zoom in on one fresh-faced guy who's
having trouble writing his he seems
nervously enthusiastic about the
operation that's about to take place and
so he Ponders and Ponders and eventually
writes the message he wants to before we
turn the page to see this
and you understand everything you need
to know about what's going through this
man's mind this is why the Mark is held
in such high regards but improperly
handed this material or you can very
much easily misconstrue what makes this
manga stand out so you know what let's
talk about Edge no not that one not that
one either there we go I'm not gonna lie
one of the biggest things that put me
off Tokyo Ghoul initially is that
judging from the anime and the fan base
that follows it it just seems like it's
trying a bit too hard to be edgy I think
this post I found sums it up perfectly
why do people think Tokyo Ghoul is an
edgy anime I had to ask this after I saw
mother's basement Tokyo Ghoul video
where he said Tokyo Ghoul was edgy and
that he'd rather watch I can't make a
kill the sugar flashbacks of how my
friends would say only Tumblr Emos or
people who shop at a Hot Topic like
Tokyo Ghoul I don't fall into any of
these descriptions
but I do use Tumblr sometimes
I often find it hard to verbalize
exactly what the difference is between a
story that's dark and adult versus
something that's edgy what makes
something like berserk mature versus
something like a karmega kill both are
filled to the room with violence have
messed up things happening throughout
the story and are full of crazy Larger
than Life characters but at the end of
the day edginess is just the feeling
that you get berserk has one of the most
engrossing stories in the history of
manga there's depth to the characters a
reason for the madness a message at the
heart of the tale that can move the
toughest of men whereas for shows like
akame ga Kill Mirai Nikki elf and liege
you get the feeling that they are trying
to be violent and shocking for the sake
of being violent and shocking watching
these giving the same feeling as seeing
a teenager trying to seem way cooler
than they actually are but where that
boundary lies can differ from person to
person and the line between mature and
edgy is something that can be paper thin
Tokyo Ghoul is a series that lives on
this line it was born there my boy
kaneki set up camp up there and is
navigating it like a goddamn trapeze
artist walking down to the tune of
Evanescence Bring Me Back To Life but
through a style of Storytelling you
should have manages to keep his manga
ever feeling like it's gone full Edge
you know for the longest time I saw this
panel of kaneki saying I am tragedy
being passed around on the internet and
I was like oh
got my life into pizza and give me a
plastic fork because this Edge is
slicing me up you know I can't deny with
this aesthetic and style out of context
this line of dialogue seems to fit
perfectly but it was only after reading
the marketer to find out that this is a
bloody parody edit Carnegie doesn't say
anything like this in the series but it
shows that all it takes is changing a
few words a few lines of dialogue for
Tokyo Ghoul to fall right down there
into the depths of edge build I felt
that he should have managed to avoid
this when I was reading the manga but in
the anime
that definitely wasn't the case and to
probably portray my points I gotta talk
about one of the big early turning
points in the manga so if you haven't
seen up to the ending of season one in
the anime then I'll be doing a spoilery
timestamp on YouTube so you can skip
ahead early on Carnegie gets kidnapped
by a powerful ghoul named Jason who
would put him through a living hell at
the time kaneki still very much viewed
himself as a human unable to accept his
ghoul side and it would be this that
completely breaks him for 10 long ruling
days Jason put kaneki through some of
the most unimaginably horrific torture
nobody should have to experience body
parts were cut off a centipede was
allowed to run rampant inside of
kaneki's ear his fingers and toes were
cut off so many times that his nails
turned black from the constant
regeneration of his Limbs and over time
his hair slowly turns from black to
white from the sheer stress and Trauma
of the event first just a strand then a
patch then by the end every single
strand was white his mind was pushed to
the breaking points and then kept going
far beyond that and at the end of it all
with nothing left cling on to no hope
left return to this absolutely grotesque
panel as you see you kind of keep
cannibalizing himself eyeballs popping
out fingers clawing his face off as he
finally accepts that he
is a ghoul seeing this panel for the
first time I got such a guttural
reaction of a mix of so many different
emotions and was such a powerful raw way
to show kaneki completely breaking down
and accepting his ghoul side now how did
the anime do this well he has a nice
friendly chat with rise before having a
little cheeky bite of her and then for
some reason his hair instantaneously
turns white and before he remembers to
wipe the Nando's sauce off his mouth we
get this
[Music]
I am a cool I'm not saying this is the
worst way to adapt it I'm not even
saying that this is a bad scene overall
but come on man can we even compare the
first time I saw this seed my guttural
reaction was oh you better watch out
Jason and edgy's in the house yes this
is the exact moment Ken kaneki becomes
Heisenberg you're goddamn right it's
small [ __ ] like this that throws off the
Nuance of emotions you get when you read
the Manga and shifts it way more into
the edgy side because yes having your
protagonist born white hair and black
nails the moment they get a badass dark
brooding power up only to have unravel
star playing is edgy as [ __ ] even if
that song is awesome even at its best
the Tokyo Ghoul anime never felt like it
captured the same visceral emotions
contained in the manga and may I remind
you this was the good adaptation because
let me tell you about the train wreck
that came afterwards right after this
came the direct sequel that they called
Tokyo Ghoul square root a which is just
what the [ __ ] does that even mean whose
bright idea was this did they just have
a chronic fear of the number two some
are out there a mathematician is crying
right now rute is a reference to and pun
on the algoody tree organization which
is the focus of the second season a is
simply the first letter of the
organization and the root is a pun on
tree root since its algeri tree but it
might be more accurate than I'm giving
it credit for because it makes about as
much sense as the [ __ ] season does to
call the season a glorified fan fiction
would be an insult to fan fictions
kaneki goes on a completely different
path making a completely anime original
adaptation except somehow stitching
things together so they kind of result
in the same climatic fights and events
but since they did this while removing
all character motivations and moments
from the manga absolutely nothing anyone
does makes sense this is what would
happen if he gave the Tokyo gulmanga to
Stevie Wonder and asked him to recreate
the events he read by removing the same
context by removing the small character
Moments by removing all Nuance in the
story not only did the developments not
make any [ __ ] sense but oh boy get
ready to walk down that Lovato Broken
Dreams because we're taking that lonely
road right into Edgefield Tokyo Ghoul is
yet another victim of a manga with an
anime adaptation that completely
squandered everything that made it great
the Tokyo Ghoul re-adaptation tried to
salvage it but by that point it was too
late and even then I just don't think
the studios were good enough to portray
the same emotions Ishida was able to
etch into his manga do I think the manga
is a masterpiece not quite I think there
was a quality dip in the later half of
re where everything started to feel a
bit of rushed and I'm not gonna lie some
of the fight scenes are just really
really hard to follow what a perfect
reason for an anime adaptation but even
though the road to get there was messy
he should have found a way to give a
conclusion to all his characters that
left me feeling absolutely satisfied
there is so much more here than the edgy
Tumblr show I originally thought it was
and I'm glad I gave it a chance Tokyo
Ghoul deserved better and I should have
listened to the side of me that ignored
my preconceptions earlier guys I guess
what I'm trying to say is
there are two wolves inside of me
hey guys hope you enjoyed that video
thank you very much this month too Alpha
sectional degenerates lf4 ivito
flabberwocky Jeff lovardos Payne patches
Pony Stark waltergeist VT and everyone
else on my patreon for helping to
support me for this month and making
this video possible as you can see guys
I am right now recording on a phone in a
hotel room and that's cause I'm on tour
in America so I won't keep this long
right now I am in Chicago and tomorrow
I'm going to be in Ohio so if you're
living in America there is still a
chance to get tickets for some of the
venues that have not sold out yet you
can go to trashtaste tour.com we've done
two shows so far and it's been so much
fun it's been absolutely incredible so
if you want to get a chance to see us
live then go to trashtaste tour.com
anyway that's it for me today no further
updates I've been gig up and I'll see
you all next time Ken Carnegie wants
[ __ ]